あぁ
インフルの注射跡が痛い。
こんにちわ　はじめしゃちょーです。はい。
という訳で今回はですね...
重要かな？
重要って言われちゃ重要かもしんないですけども
重要じゃないっていったら重要じゃありません。
まぁ個人的なこっち側の動きの話なんですけども、
えっと、お話させていただきます。（ﾍﾟｺﾘ
昔から僕の動画を見てる方ならわかると思うんですけども
僕動画の中で今の状況とか思ったことを
結構言っちゃうタイプなんですよ
無理したくなくて。
無理したくないんで　例えば大学が忙しかったときは
大学が忙しいぜ！
はい！みたいな
なんか動画と
動画の世界と現実の世界を割り切ることをせず
なるべくありのままの自分で動画にいってるつもりなので
ちょっと...それを踏まえて、
今回のお話をさせていただきます。
ま、ほんとに個人的な話なんですけども
ま、タイトルにある通り
新メンバーが入ります。
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
といっても、多分皆さんの想像しているような新メンバーではありません
まぁ、今までですね
まさきは結構出てくれてるんですけども
基本的には一人で僕のやりたい事を
今までもこのチャンネルでやって来たので
今後もそれは多分ずっと変わらない
と思います。わかんないけどね。
ひょっとしたら変わるかもしんないけど
基本的には僕が一人動画に出て
僕のしたいことを
友達とか、後輩とか、他のYoutuber
まさきとかと、楽しくやってくていう
スタンスは変わらないんですけれども
今回増える新メンバーっていうのは
そういう動画に出てくる人が増えるというわけじゃなくて
一緒に動画を作ってくれ*ｂｇm…
一緒に動画を作ってくれる人が一人増えるという、
二人だったね
一人増えるという意味でございます。
まぁ、要するに何だろうな
裏方さんです。
裏方さんが一人増えます。
まぁちょっとその理由としては
いろいろと長くなるんですけども、
みんなさんご存じの通り
大学を卒業してからぐらいかな。
それまでも結構行ってたんですけども、
極端に
いや、ありがたいお話なんですけど
ありがたいことに、極端に
東京に行くことがめちゃくちゃ多くなりまして、
多い時だと、週3、4、5とかかな
ほぼ東京にいる時もあったり、
かと言って東京に住みたくもないんですよね。
この部屋もいいし、
この部屋を貸してくださってる大家さんも
すごい理解があって、
『もう暴れちゃってください』って言ってくれるし、
やっぱ静岡にいてくれる僕の友達とか、後輩がね
みんないい人なんです。
本当に何か動画撮った時も、
すぐ手伝ってくれたり
僕もしたいですって言ってくれる仲間たちが多くて、
静岡にいるやつらとの居心地がよくて
かつ地味にね。
東京もそんな遠いわけじゃないので
今までなんとかやってきてこれてるんで
まぁそういう意味もあって
すごい静岡いいなと思って、
今ずっと静岡にいるんですけども
まぁ基本的に僕は静岡で楽しく、
動画を撮ってるのが性に合っているんで
そのスタンスは今まで変わらないと思います。
で、ですね。
その東京に行くことが極端に多くなってからですね。
あのー…。
メインチャンネル、この動画です。
このメインチャンネルの動画を作るために
割けることができる時間が、
かなり減ってしまいました。
まあ、中には結構無理して動画を撮ったりね
うおーーーって焦りながら編集したりすることも結構多くなっちゃって、
僕の中でやっぱそれだとダメだなって思ったり、
ちょっとこれ無理してやってるなって思うことも
何度かあったりして、
ちょっと僕の中で
これはなんとかしなきゃなっていうのが
今年の夏ぐらいですね…。
今年の夏ぐらいにちょっと思ってたので、
まあ、弟をつけたり、して。
色々調整したりして
やってたんですけども。
さすがに
やばいな、と。
まあ、僕ですね。
で僕、スタンス的には
1日1本作るのがすごい、合ってるんですよ。
1日1本したいことを動画にして、
編集も全力でして、
もう、「おらああああ、1本出来たぜえええ！！！」
みたいな。
その、なんか、楽しさがあって。すごい。
YouTube楽しくてやってて、
基本的に僕東京に行くときは
何か用事があって東京にいるので、
東京だと動画の撮影ができない
編集する時間も無い。
朝から夜まで基本的には全部何か入ってるんで、
まあ、実質その日の動画は撮れないんですよね…。
まあ、ホントに無理な時は休みますよ。
ホントに無理なときは僕全然平気で休んじゃうんですけど、
見てくださる方が多くて
非常にありがたいので
できればね、できれば
毎日動画は出したいと思ってるんで、
まあ、東京にいる時は基本的に
その前の日の静岡にいる時に徹夜で編集して、
1本動画作ってから
（。ｄ。）
こんな顔で東京に行くっていう。
なんで僕、基本的に東京にいる時
あの…、
体調悪いです。
っていう生活が続いておりました。今年は。
基本的にそんな感じ
『前もって、動画撮っとけよ。』
って言えばそれで終わりなんですけどぉ…。
んー、僕はやっぱねえ
1日…1本作るのが楽しいです。
2本作ったら
たぶん2本目マジで面白くないから。
イヤ、作ってる僕がね。
作ってる僕がたぶん面白くないと思うんで、
まあ楽しくいきたいわけなんすよぉ！
楽しく。
というわけで結構その東京−静岡の行き来が多すぎて、
洗濯を取り込む時間も無い
洗濯干してる間にたぶん東京に行かなきゃいけなくて…、
洗濯干せないってタイミングが多かったり…。
で、僕自体掃除しないってのもあるんですけども、
まあ、根本的に掃除をする時間とかね…。
ゴミを捨てる曜日とかも決まってるわけで、
なかなかゴミも捨てる…
ってか今部屋すごいからね！
まあ見ての通りちょっとね荒れに荒れてます
ここら辺もひどいねえ…。
こ、これでもひょっとしたら俺が掃除をしないのはあるな。
オイラが掃除しないのは多分…
ちょびっとあるとは思うんですけど、
まぁもうちょっと時間あったらひょっとしたら掃除するかもしんないすね…。
ていう言い訳です！
というですね…、
僕の中で一番大切にしているメインチャンネルの動画作りっていう時間が少ないのは、
本当に宜しくないなと思ってまして
実はちょいちょい、
このメンバーを…入れるっていうのを進めていまして
で、まあ全然まさきとはポジションが違うんですけども。
えーと、新メンバーがやることは、えっと…
まぁ編集とか、動画の編集とか
撮影の手伝い。
カメラとかね、なんか物を買ったり運んだりするっていう
どっちかっていうと僕の周りの事を
一緒にサポートしてくれるメンバーなので
動画には出ません
動画には出ないですね
なんかね　まさきにカメラを回させてもさ
最近まさきもばれちゃってるから
そこでばれちゃって　もう
そもそも撮影にならないっていうパターンが
多くなってきたんで
裏方さんみたいな人がちょっと
今後必要かなと、思いまして、
今回の決断に、至りました。
というわけでね　えっと、そいつはですね僕の友達なんですけど
やる気はあるんですけど　全然編集もしたことないし、
Youtubeのこともあんまり詳しくないので
今後そういうことをいろいろ教えていってですね、
まぁ　最終的にどんどんできることを増やしていって
まぁそうなることによって　僕の時間ができるわけです！
今まで編集したりね　なんか
物を買ったり運んだり
いろんな作業を、
えーっと分担することによって
僕の時間が結構出来るので
メインチャンネルに僕が割ける時間が　少しでも
増えてくれたら良いなと　思っております
うん
というお話。　なんで！全然、
見てる皆さん！　僕の動画は多分あんま変わんないです
ひょっとしたら　新メンバーのやつが編集して
ちょっといつもと違う感じになるかも
しれないですけど
それも徐々に成長していくと思うので
基本的にみてる皆さんには変化がないです
まあ僕の顔色がちょっとよくなるぐらい！　かな？
という　気がします。笑
というお知らせでございます
今年もうちょいあるんですけども
なかなかね
メインチャンネルもっとがんばりたかったなぁ〜…て思う
ことが！　多い！
1年でした。
まだ終わってないけどね
そろそろソロプレイも　終わりです、
ダジャレじゃないですよ
ひとりでねYoutubeやるのって
ほんとに結構大変でして
HIKAKINさんてまじですごいからね！
ヒカキンさんまじですごいから！
親分は本当すごいと思いますよ。
僕はちょっと　静岡−東京行き来してるなかで
ちょっとひとりだと限界だなと思って
身の回りのことも　メインチャンネルで動画出すことも
思ったようにうまくいかないなと　思ったので
ともに面白い物を　何か作ってくれる
仲間を　一人入ることに　なりました。
はい！　というおしらせでございます！
もう　思ったこと全部言ったぞ！
僕は　今年ちょっとそういう感じで
モヤモヤした1年だった！
今後はそういった感じで！！　私、
そして　たまたまたまに　まさき！
なんか下ネタみたいになっちゃった、
そしてもう一人顔はださないんですけど
新メンバーの三人体制で！
あ！　プラス静岡の俺の友達と後輩ね！！
まぁ　みんなで力を合わせて今後も
今後も楽しくやっていこうと思います
明日から！　その、
新体制で始動するので、
今後とも、　はじめしゃちょーをよろしくおねがいします。
ポケモン殿堂入りしました。
じゃあな！
♪～